bei dieser spektakulären entdeckung
könnte es sich möglicherweise um eine
klasse schwarzer löcher handeln die
bislang noch nie eindeutig nachgewiesen
werden konnte so genannte intermediäre
schwarze löcher fachleute haben ein
signal aufgespürt das von einer äußerst
ungewöhnlichen kollision herrührt und
auch die beiden ausgangs schwarzen
löcher waren anders als alle bisher
beobachteten klicks zum science and
future gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen und am ende gibt es noch
einen sneak preview den gängigen
astronomischen modellen zufolge können
diese beobachtung eigentlich gar nicht
stimmen denn sowohl die beiden ausgangs
schwarzen löcher sind mit ihren 85 und
66 sonnenmassen deutlich schwerer als
alle anderen die astronomie teams
bislang mit hilfe der bürger und lego
observatorien beobachtet haben und auch
das objekt das aus der verschmelzung
dieser beiden giganten entstanden ist
ist ein echter rekord denn es weiß ganz
so 142 sonnenmassen auf und somit könnte
es tatsächlich das erste eindeutig
nachgewiesene intermediäre schwarze loch
überhaupt sein und das wäre eine echte
sensation dazu der astronomen das
schenken in der an der aktuellen studie
beteiligt war aber trotz langer suche
hat man solche intermediären schwarzen
löcher von 100 bis 100 tausend
sonnenmassen bislang nicht beobachtet
doch von vorne
entdeckt wurden die beiden schwarzen
löcher von einem forschungsteam der lego
und wirkung kollaboration das sind die
beiden einzigen gravitationswellen auch
zu erzeugen die es weltweit gibt am 21
mai des vergangenen jahres 2009 10
bereits hatten die fachleute einen
gravitationswellen signal aufgespürt das
die bezeichnung gw 19 05 21 bekam sowohl
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler der beiden laico
detektoren in den usa als auch ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen am
italienischen bürger gravitationswellen
detektor konnten diese schwingung
detektieren die darauf hinweisen dass
zwei besonders massereiche objekte
verschmäht
die messungen der gravitationswellen auf
serien lie usa und bürger italien laufen
in einem sogenannten interferenz
experiment bei dem ein laserstrahl in
zwei teile strahlen aufgespalten wird
die lichtwellen werden in zwei röhren
geleitet die exakt gleich lang sind und
senkrecht also im 90 grad winkel
aufeinander stehen am ende steht ein
spiegel der es reflektiert und
zurückwirft wenn sich die strahlen also
die beiden lichtwellen im normalfall
eliminieren bzw aufheben gibt es kein
signal dann löschen sich die beiden
lichtwellen gegeneinander aus kann
jedoch ein signal gemessen werden liegt
dies an einer gravitationswellen die die
raumzeit verzerrt denn dadurch variiert
die länge der röhren und die laufzeit
eine gravitationswellen hat die raumzeit
gekrümmt die messungen müssen wirklich
sehr sehr genau sein da der effekt der
gravitationswellen sehr sehr klein ist
hierbei handelt es sich eben um
stauchungen und dehnung in struktur von
raum und zeit die sich in form von
gravitationswellen mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit wellenförmig
ausbreiten und die hatte tatsächlich
arbeiten stand schon vor mehr als 100
jahren vorhergesagt er war nur davon
ausgegangen dass sie so schwach sind
dass wir sie nie messen können aber in
der jüngeren vergangenheit gab es etwa
ein dutzend spannende neue einzeln
entdeckung die nach und nach ein
gesamtbild dieser super spannenden
gravitationswellen ereignisse ergeben
ein neuer wissenschaftszweig war durch
lago und bürger geboren worden
die gravitationswellen astronomie und
jetzt schon wieder ein äußerst
spannendes und zugleich auch
rätselhaftes signal rätselhaft weil
diese schwingungen eine besonders hohe
intensität als auch eine niedrige
frequenz auf wiesen sogar für die
fachleute selbst eine besonders
überraschende premiere dazu der astronom
nelson christensen das signal war
weniger ein schuppen wie wir es
typischerweise delektieren als vielmehr
ein richtiger denn es ist das
massereichste signal dass leide und wird
wohl jemals beobachtet haben
ein ganz besonderer fall also der auf
eine ganz besonders außergewöhnliche
kollision schließen lässt zuerst einmal
zu der besonderheit der beiden ausgangs
schwarzen löcher die in keine der beiden
kategorien passen von der die wissen
bislang ausgegangen ist in die eine
rubrik ordnen fachleute supermassereiche
giganten ein die bis zu zehn milliarden
sonnenmassen aufweisen und sich im
zentrum von galaxien befinden ein
beispiel dafür
barrios r stern im herzen der
milchstraße auf der anderen seite dann
stellare schwarze löcher die durch die
supernova massereicher sterne entstehen
nach meinung der fachleute kann diese
art schwarzer löcher nicht mehr als 65
sonnenmassen aufweisen laut der
sogenannten paar instabilität theorie
dürfte es im bereich von 65 bis 120
sonnenmassen keine schwarzen löcher
geben
die erklärung dazu hängt mit der
entstehung der stellaren schwarzen
löcher zusammen die durch die supernova
eines massereichen sterns entstehen
ausgangs sterne die sehr schwer sind
nämlich explodieren nicht als supernova
stattdessen kommt es zu instabilen
episoden in denen die ausgangs sterne
innerhalb kürzester zeit einen großen
teil ihrer masse abstoßen heißt also im
klartext dass diese sterne bei diesem
prozess schrumpfen bei ihrer explosion
kann somit nur ein schwarzes loch
entstehen dass maximal 65 sonnenmassen
aufweist heißt also in bezug auf die so
genannte paar installiert es lücke das
ab 65 sonnenmassen schluss ist ab 120
sonnenmassen allerdings können schwarze
löcher demzufolge wieder existieren und
zwar aus dem folgenden grund hier sind
sterne im spiel
die mehr als 200 sonnenmassen aufweisen
und direkt zum schwarzen loch ab etwa
120 sonnenmassen kollabieren ohne dabei
zu explodieren oder zu schrumpfen
so also entsteht diese lücke zwischen 65
und 120 sonnenmassen in der es der
theorie zufolge keine schwarzen löcher
geben dürfte soweit die theorie
doch die realität ist möglicherweise
eine ganz andere
darauf weist zumindest die aktuelle
entdeckung des gravitationswellen
signals gw 19 05 21 in der vergangenheit
dagegen hatten astronomische
beobachtungen dieser astrophysikalischen
parin stabilitäts theorie immer
entsprochen und mittlerweile sind es
tatsächlich schon einige verschmelzungen
von schwarzen löchern die aufgespürt
werden konnten und zwar weil
gravitationswellen detektiert werden
konnten
mit dabei sogar auf die kollision eines
schwarzen lochs mit einem neutronenstern
ebenso auf kollisionen von sehr
ungleichen partnern heißt also die nun
aufgespürten schwarzen löcher weisen
eine extrem große masse auf und genau
das wirft viele rätsel auf dazu der us
astronom alan weinstein dieses ereignis
wirft mehr fragen auf als es beantwortet
aus der sicht der physik ist das eine
sehr spannende sache spannend vor allem
auch das entstanden das schwarze loch
das 142 sonnenmassen aufweist damit
bewegte sich in der lücke die die
sogenannten intermediären schwarzen
löcher schließen könnten
diese könnten nämlich 100 bis 100000 mal
schwerer sein als die sonne
sie legen somit im zwischenbereich
zwischen den stelen schwarzen löchern
und den supermassereichen schwarzen
löchern der galaxienkerne quasi das
missing link im spektrum der schwarzen
löcher mit dabei unter anderem auch ein
schwarzes loch mit 428 sonnenmassen und
in den randbereichen anderer galaxien
mehrere auffällige röntgenquellen
vielversprechend unter anderem ein
objekt mit starker röntgenstrahlung und
bereits 2006 dem visier der beiden
röntgenteleskop chandra und xmm newton
doch damals gelang es den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern nicht die röntgenquelle
genauer zu lokalisieren anfang diesen
jahres hat aber ein us forschungsteam
das objekt mit der bezeichnung die unten
eingeblendet ist weil sie viel zu lange
ist noch einmal genauer unter die lupe
genommen und zwar unter anderem mit
hilfe des weltraumteleskops hubble
so konnten beispielsweise die größe und
die nähere umgebung des objekts näher
bestimmt werden
das röntgen spektrum verriet dann auch
lager und art des objekts und somit war
klar es handelt sich keineswegs um einen
namen neutronenstern sondern um ein
schwarzes loch das im randbereich der
galaxie gall 1 liegt und zwar
höchstwahrscheinlich in einem
sternhaufen und noch mehr konnten die us
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
herausfinden nämlich dass dieses
schwarze loch über 50 tausend
sonnenmassen verfügt und daher zu einem
der aussichtsreichen kandidaten für ein
intermediäre schwarzes loch zählt die
beobachtung lassen darauf schließen dass
dieses schwarze loch auf frischer tat
ertappt wurde und zwar beim zerstören
eines nahen stern so wird material
freigesetzt die um das schwarze loch
dank
heißt und sehr stark aufgeheizt und
beschleunigt wird und genau diese aktion
führt zu der intensiven röntgenstrahlung
die es ermöglichte dass möglicherweise
eben intermediäre schwarze loch
aufzuspüren dazu der wissenschaftler
da schenkt in der an der studie
beteiligt war die tatsache dass dieses
schwarze loch einem stern zerreißt
liefert und starke belege dafür dass es
nicht bloß ein stellares schwarzes loch
sein kann denn noch viel mehr ist über
dieses objekt nicht bekannt die großen
fragen lauten wie entstehen solche
intermediären schwarzen löcher und wie
entwickeln sie sich handelt es sich bei
den schwarzen löchern dieser masse um
kosmische ausreißer bei der aktuellen
entdeckung der verschmelzung gegen 19 05
21 sind es also nicht nur die beiden
ausgangs objekte die alle rekorde
sprengen auch das daraus resultierende
schwarze loch hat es mit 142
sonnenmassen in sich es handelt sich
tatsächlich um die höchste gesamtmasse
die forschungsteams weltweit jemals
beobachten konnten
doch die verschmelzung der beiden
schwarzen löcher ist schon ewig her
dieses ereignis fand nämlich bereits vor
7 milliarden jahren statt in einem
universum das zu diesem zeitpunkt halb
so alt war wie heutzutage
doch die gravitationswellen waren enorm
und genau das führte dazu dass sie
überhaupt bei uns ankamen und detektiert
werden konnten und das aus einer
gewaltigen entfernung von eben sieben
milliarden lichtjahren und das wundert
nicht schließt sich wurde durch die
kollision der beiden schwarzen löcher
das energie äquivalent der siebenfachen
sonnenmasse ausgesendet und das ist
wirklich unglaublich viel energie nur
deshalb waren die gravitationswellen
hier überhaupt messbar
man darf nicht vergessen dass die
energie solche ereignisse mit dem
quadrat der entfernung umgekehrt
proportional singt es müssen schon
unglaubliche energien seien die in einer
entfernung von sieben milliarden
lichtjahren noch besser sind die us
fachleute bewerten ihre beobachtung als
spektakulär denn sie sind sich sicher
dass es sich um die lange gesuchten
zwischenform im kosmos handelt dazu der
forscher christopher berry jetzt haben
wir den beleg dafür dass diese
intermediären schwarzen löcher
existieren und diese überaus
überraschende entdeckung könnte nach an
der forschungsteams wohl nur der anfang
sein dazu der physiker frank ohne jedem
es saison von nikon büro hat uns bisher
neue einblicke in unser universum
eröffnet es ist offensichtlich dass wir
gerade erst begonnen haben die vielfalt
der paare von schwarzen löchern dort
draußen zu verstehen die fachleute
setzten darauf dass in zukunft immer
längere beobachtungszeit möglich sind
und auch die detektoren immer sensitiver
werden und das könnte die forschung
enorm weiterbringen denn durch solche
beobachtung lassen sich nicht nur die
entstehungsgeschichte schwarzer löcher
für besser nachvollziehen sondern auch
die expansionsgelüste danßmann vom max
planck institut für gravitationsphysik
bald wenn wir alle verschmelzungen
schwarzer löcher analysiert haben die
lager und büro in ihrem dritten
beobachtungs lauf beobachtet haben
wissen wir hoffentlich mehr
was passiert in einem schwarzen loch
also hier anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren und zwar doktor watson ein
wirklich genialer wissenschafts kanal
der seine videos wirklich mit
unglaublich viel einsatz machte das ist
das eigentlich bald mehr dazu bis dann
bleibt dran